[موسيقى]
في مبادره امتدت لعشر سنوات
ذهبت عائله الركبي في مدينه عرعر بمنطقه
الحدود الشماليه السعوديه على افطار
الصائمين طيله شهر رمضان هذه المبادره
ابتدا بها والدي رحمه الله عليه رحمه من
عشر سنوات ونحن ان شاء الله مستمرون بهذه
المبادره والحمد لله العائله كلها من
كبيرها الى صغيرها مشارك في اعداد هذه
الماء الجبهه الجماعيه وكلهم خليه نحل
داخلي لا احكي لك كيف يعملون من الظهر الى
تقديم الوجبه
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
هذه المبادره التي لقيت صدا واسعا يشاركها
الجيران باحضار بعض الاطباق من منازلهم في
اجواء تسودها المحبه
واهل كرم واهل خير الناس كلها بتفطر هنا
وبتطلع مبسوطه واحلى فطار اصنافهم متنوعه
من الاطعمه الرمضانيه يتم طهيها في مطبخي
هذه العائله التي تكاتفت على تجهيز
الافطار من الكبار والصغار
العائله تجهز السمبوسه كذلك الشوربه
الوجبه الرئيسيه اللي هي الرز الكبسه هذه
الوجبه الرئيسيه السعوديه كذلك الايدامات
كريمه محلبيه حسب المتوفر في هذا اليوم من
الصنف الحاله
والعصائر والالبان
[موسيقى]
من مدينه عرعر جزاع النصي العربيه لمتابعه
المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج والقصص
الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات